voilà la situation à hyères pin de plus
en plus de d'habitants qui espérait
pouvoir rester chez eux et bien qu'ils
influent ce matin et je peux vous dire
que effectivement on parler aujourd'hui
la journée s'était ouverte avec l'idée
d'un cessez-le-feu et d'un corridor
humanitaire
il y à des bombardements incessants
depuis ce matin ici haïr pin une
intensification très claire des
bombardements et de l'offensive qui
maintenant des bombardements qui frappe
à quelques centaines de mètres à gauche
et filles dansaient bois aussi des
bombardements très important ce qui
laisse entendre que les la question de
corridors humanitaires et bien n'est pas
du tout respecté bien au contraire c'est
une intensification des combats qui a
lieu ici au porte de kiev
poutine est un [__] lukashenko est un
[__]
dealer boris serpil ne tombera jamais
irvine restera ukrainienne
il peinait à nous ils pin ne tombera pas
[Musique]
vous les russes on vous conseille de
rentrer à la maison rentrée avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard pour vous et que vous
reveniez dans des cercueils
comme on peut l'être le plus voir ce
sont des soldats qui repartent au au
front qui font des allers retours il y a
malgré les bombardements
rapprochement évident des combats et
bien il ya un esprit de résistance
farouche et ils ont bon moral ils nous
ont dit qu'ils allaient gagner cette
guerre il ya qui repartaient au front on
a pu voir des tireurs d'élite des
snipers quelques volontaires étrangers
qui commencent à arriver sur ce front
voilà l'avant-poste ukrainien dans les
replis nous sommes c'est l'avenue
principale il ya des soldats à
l'ukrainien posté dans plusieurs bunkers
donc il y a maintenant un flux toujours
en voiture de gens qui fuient cette
ville c'est une ville totalement morte
encore une fois c'est comme si le temps
s'était arrêté ici avec cette offensive
russe